in five four three two one what's up
everybody welcome to another episode of
the genius brain podcast we got a very
special [ __ ] guest today one of
the funniest [ __ ] on the
Internet till this mother [ __ ]
day you stupid smelly sons of [ __ ]
it's keV on [ __ ] stage you
fluent lien free I love you know why I
started cursing a lot when I was younger
it was actually a way for me to cope
with punching things so I used to get so
angry when I was younger I used to get a
lot of fistfights really they used to
punch it a lot so this these two if you
look at these two knuckles right here
these is gone they just down here
because I just had a really bad anger
problem when I was a kid so instead of
getting angry getting two fistfights and
punching people I just decided to curse
and just verbally let it out and is that
was that relaxing and therapeutic
yes it's very therapeutic I love it now
it's just a part of my vernacular which
I'm trying to get rid of it a little bit
but it's hard oh it's so you though
it is and that's the funny thing with
like the YouTube monetization thing it
gets me hard because I curse a lot
yeah and arguably there's a lot of
people who put up worse content than I
do absolutely yeah you too bro YouTube
hates so my comments have been off on my
channel for like 7 months now why cuz
that whole pedophile thing you remember
that yeah yeah yeah so that ho pedophile
ring I used to have my kids on my
channel a lot so apparently like my
channel got flagged like pedophile I
don't know what it was maybe my kids
swimming or something like that but they
would put like the number where kids had
their shirt off or we're dancing
suggestively or whatever and it would
make playlists so for whatever reason my
channel got flagged like hey this guy be
having kids in his videos so you to turn
off every comment on all my videos
moving forward so for the last since
like February and I fought back with
them and stuff and they're just like nah
man so I'm like hit up YouTube creators
to top people YouTube was trying to bug
me on my brain I'll try to book me I
can't even get my comments on so it was
like killing my channel so I had to
start a whole new YouTube channel and
start from scratch because people I
broke I want to comment yeah it's part
of the whole experience to comment like
so in the video I click on and as I'm
listening I really come and see what
people are saying so I'm just like bruh
you to be I don't really care about
creators at all it's it's once it became
a business model yeah that's when the
creator
aspect of it starting to disappear right
because yeah at the end of the day when
you look at people who have arguably a
lot worse content than us they get a
pass it's because their view count is so
high Logan Paul look at him a lot of
this stuff started from that suicide for
his video they want to make sure they
could still advertise him knew they had
to punch punish the rest of the
community yeah so cuz I was that whole
thing is infuriating right that's like
that boy makes so much money man like
it's weird because I think for somebody
like that he got he has a god complex
and I'm not giving him a pass or
anything but when you don't know any
better it's like that whole Justin
Bieber effect right everybody is a yes
men around him yes he doesn't know any
better like my kid Bieber I remember
when I saw this video it was him playing
ball right right I think he lightweight
crossed somebody up and he went ooh do
the camera was like number one relax
number two that [ __ ] wasn't dope and
number three you're not black so relax
just cuz like I should cosign you
doesn't make you black right [ __ ]
relax kid because nobody smacked them
before and that's what happened he broke
and he slap across his face yes and the
bigger you are the less likely people
are to tell you anything that might put
them in position to lose that
relationship with you oh for sure Robin
are Kelly's like Bros he can't even book
tickets cuz he can't read if you were
like I know this is illegal but I gotta
get paid that documentary I always say
it's it's it's not even really about him
it's about everybody else that knew he
was [ __ ] up and they just gave him a
pass people were not trying to mess up
their check yeah like if I've if this
cost me my own job
bro do what you do he would patrol
around elementary Scarborough it was a
laugh so that's what I say it's like who
are you first are you a human first are
you a comic first because when I laughed
throughout that whole thing and I was in
tears laughing because they just had
like the most dramatic scenes of him
walking next to an elementary school
like in black and white I'm like this is
[ __ ] this is a Dave Chapelle sketch
this is a Dave Chappelle sketch but it's
real life right this is the real ass and
people still defend him just like right
now like his fans bailed him out of jail
honey grand for me to get arrested like
three weeks later now you're out of
$100,000 he held out by his fans yes a
fan of his was like a lawyer in another
state put up a hundred grand to bail him
out and he got arrested on another set
of charges like
three weeks after that oh my god that's
crazy people just don't care man
his interview with Gayle King was the
one that did him in though what a home
time I was like this is just gold you
must don't just say you did it a day
when he the funniest part was like you
know what my problem is Gayle she's like
what he was like I got such a big heart
you really believe that is your problem
that you have a big heart
and people take advantage of you no
that's a [ __ ] big dick that goes into
kids you little [ __ ] rapist is your
problem that is your real problem not
your big heart that [ __ ] was
crazy it's crazy because you can't
really get a pass on anything nowadays
not that he should I'm just saying yeah
yeah if you have done something terrible
in your life is going to come to light
absolutely it's just simple people
people can find any man listen they
people be finding old tweets when their
man cuz I pissed off a whole bunch of
Taylor Swift fans like a week or so ago
oh what'd you say I just so somebody
tweeted when her fans was like man she
looks mixed here Taylor Swift look
Taylor Swift and a picture of Taylor
Swift and I'm like I mean come on like
she look Milton I was making all these
jug like she's making with ninety
percent milk and ten percent milk and
Greek yogurt and cottage cheese like
what is Taylor Swift mixed with but what
did she say she look mixed with black
like it was it you say but it was like
hinted that she looked black cuz it was
kind of like a dark filter or whatever
so I'm assuming in men but I but it
wasn't even matter what the race was she
looked like notebook paper and all fours
so her fans got mad at me and they were
like he'd been tweeting her for Klout
forever and they found a video I did of
her like she [ __ ] like so three years
ago and I totally forgot I made this
video completely if I make a video like
literally every day yeah and I was
completely forgot I made it yeah I
really tweeted keV on stage Taylor Swift
and search to see how often I talked
about her people and all these people's
their profile picture was her every
tweet was about her like when she
released music how they feel about this
song this interview she did people
I'm not y'all really need to do
something else we do yourself a favor
and step in front of the car you speak
the sense of [ __ ] how about that I
mean
tell you this Taylor Swift don't give a
[ __ ] about you Taylor Swift doesn't give
a [ __ ] about you you think that if you
pray to her [ __ ] altar she's gonna
come down some day and give you a
[ __ ] hand and anything in your life
let me tell you something here you
stupid sons of [ __ ] nobody gives a
[ __ ] about you how about that you had
the crazies Kevin's you're somebody
that's why I didn't care if I said that
[ __ ] nobody gives a [ __ ] right you know
you think like Taylor Swift even cares
like she does salute it's not like
you're making fun of Taylor Swift you're
making fun of the people that thought
she's mixed exactly so I was like what
are you defending yeah are you arguing
that she does in fact look mixed that's
not that couldn't be true yeah so it's
just like a people with the internet
it's crazy though what are you gonna do
she looks white is fine bruh there's
like no other celebrity that looks more
white than her like she is the poster
child for a white woman like fan though
she's on a bag of iron kids [ __ ] name
is hey that is the whitest name like
stop she's white you who started that
[ __ ] that's [ __ ] unreal I don't know
man then you [ __ ] [ __ ] it I
look I look real mixed I'm a 6-foot
Asian yes I'm mixed with a little black
dude and [ __ ] that everybody just want
to be black nowadays man huh it's the
cool thing to do until the police pull
up you know that's you know it's funny
because Twitter always got some crazy
[ __ ] popping up and I think there was
something not too long ago where did he
was talking about it was a weird comic
because I don't know how to feel about
it because Diddy was putting up a video
of these kids kind of dancing to like
hip-hop music yeah yeah white kids and
rose he doesn't like the fact that white
kids are appropriating black culture
mm-hm and then I was like okay I can
kind of see that right yeah then I saw
another flip with somebody responded to
him they go that's funny that you say
that you don't like that these white
kids are appropriating black culture but
you are the ones selling it to them that
they should do it
so because you're profiting off of them
that's spending the most money on you
absolutely so you're the source of it so
definitely who are you to say anything
yes because without without white people
buying music and going and concerts
rappers wouldn't be as rich as they are
why people suburb suburban kids they
were buying music merch ticket prices
like
all that stuff like they consume if not
more than then black people a lot of
times and there's also much more white
people in America so you you're right
that is your customer base but I feel
like the thing that as a black person
the thing that's like frustrating it's
like people get to do all the black
stuff my can participate in everything
that black people create and often
monetize it more than black people can
yeah and they never they never reap any
of the negative benefit yeah so like hot
girls summer for example like making the
stallion coin that term hot girl summer
she's black beautiful black woman from
Houston white makeup brands I'm like are
you ready to have a hot girl summer they
don't know who making a stallion is
they're just profiting off of something
she created she's never gonna see a dime
from any of that and you know two months
from now they're not gonna you know even
be using that term anymore so she
created something people profit off it
don't give anything to her and they move
on that's having a black people over and
over and over yeah so just be like bro
y'all never have to deal with none of
this stuff but it's cool to do to engage
in what we helped create so it's kind of
like a no that makes it that makes a lot
of sense is kind of like how Asian
people feel about kind of our food right
so for when I was a kid and if I had to
bring Asian people food right let's say
I brought something basic like [ __ ]
noodles or chow mein right yeah like
white people got their spaghetti and
[ __ ] but if I brought chow mein it's
like oh you're eating [ __ ] worms but
now you see a lot of white chef they
come up and they go this is how you
should eat the food this is not how I
feel but this is how a lot of Asian
people feel it's like oh so you it's
cool not because you do it yes you know
but when I did it I got made fun of for
it right absolutely same thing with like
how when dreads were really popping with
white people they started coming out
with the dread thing and it's like wait
wasn't that supposed to be dirty people
here like I said exactly but once why
people get attached to it it's cool it's
safe you know saying so that's what's
frustrating for minorities all all of it
I remember I was watching this dude
Gordon the dude from Hell's Kitchen he
was trying to tell some asian dude how
to make noodles in the dew was like bro
this trash the Asian dude didn't care
who he was Gordon Ramsay do was like
this is the worst-looking noodles I've
been like you should even be cooking me
you should even say you're a chef this
is so but he's like know how to put a
spin on it like bran ah like take this
[ __ ] out of my [ __ ] yeah this is the
word and it's like you're saying it's
like a basic being like you shouldn't be
cooking this food if you can't mash
this yeah you don't try the other stuff
and it was just so funny cuz I bet why
be like oh we really be doing this yeah
I put up this tweet that people really
[ __ ] with it was that when Gordon Ramsay
was putting up this recipe for the best
tacos every other site listen your
British ass [ __ ] taco bro Dawg there's
people in the United States they can't
do tacos well unless it from California
and they're Mexican you know I don't
know what the [ __ ] you're talking about
dude your taco was black with a capital
H black and I love Gordon Ramsay - this
is weird phase 2 where people are going
I don't know how I feel about this and I
want to know your opinion on this yeah
like I always find I get a white guilt
the funniest thing to me because it's I
know somebody that posts every other
it's the story post is about how white
people should repent for their sins and
he's like the widest [ __ ] I've
ever met in my life and he's quoting
like Martin Luther King everybody
yeah and he's trying to make white
people feel as bad as possible for being
white and for me when I see that I'm
just like man you're doing too much bro
you wanna be on this side over here but
you ain't yourself he hates his skin
like I think he hates himself but he
wakes up and he's like [ __ ] yeah here he
goes [ __ ] you and your pale ass skin
dude you and your white privilege and
then he goes he starts whipping himself
in his bathroom you [ __ ] I'll show you
his post he's a really cool dude I love
that dude a lot but I started looking at
his post I was like damn bro you really
hate me white boy as black people we're
not asking that yeah like I think a lot
of times all we want is like the mere
acknowledgment mmm like bro just oh you
don't have to obviously you you know
he's like I didn't own slaves obviously
you you personally didn't own slaves and
maybe your family didn't either but that
doesn't mean you don't reap the benefit
of white people like I feel like I was
talking about this this is a really
interesting examiner with Sons of
Anarchy yeah okay so the motorcycle show
if you guys don't know about it
motorcycle show about white bikers and
they commit crimes to do all this stuff
right so I remember like I have to show
went up I was driving up to four or five
and I saw like a group of bikers alright
man they're probably gonna go sell some
drugs or guns and I
like dang why would I think that like I
don't know these guys yeah and I
realized the media is the reason I
thought that because I watched that show
now take that to black people and how
many times on the news you've seen black
drug dealers and black people parade
across your screen and and they're thugs
all the way back to slavery like they
want to rape our white women that's what
these black people want to do when in
fact it was really white slave masters
who were raping black women but they
flipped it around and made people scared
of black people so now you have that
bias that you don't even realize you've
been internalizing your whole life if
you're not black you like many people
are probably scared so even black people
sometimes you see black people coming
with a hoodie in your Lowrey lock my
door yeah because so many times you're
afraid of big black guy in hoodie he's
menacing like that stuff happens to me
all the time we're in stores people
follow us around all that type of stuff
you realize like part of that isn't you
personally but it's you being a part of
society in society's painting black
people especially black men one way all
the time you internalize that and I
don't even realize that there's a huge
example of that where I talked about it
earlier in the podcast is when I first
started my best friend he's Rwandan big
all black do six foot one mmm we took
this picture in a bar right it was me it
was his cousin's right so the hero
katako Gobbo and me and then one of his
other buddies was a he's a neurosurgeon
mmm and we just took a picture cuz I
haven't seen these guys in a minute and
they're like family we work together in
Sacramento yeah we took a big photo and
then you know one of the top comments
was babies trying to get his his hood
car and I'm like a hood card cost like
his these two dudes it hurts me Mom is
the ambassador for Rwanda he's a doctor
and that's a neurosurgeon yeah but
they're black though yeah they're
probably familiar and nothing about what
they were wearing anything about hood
[ __ ] and they kind of clicked in my head
I was like oh that's interesting you
know I'm not trying to be on some walk
[ __ ] but for me I'm like I'm in that
group a picture on the piece of [ __ ] so
I'm standing here like damn I deserve to
be in this photo when you see that I
guess image wise I guess for people who
didn't grow up around black people it's
more like that's the the stuff that
they're fed absolutely so for them what
they see is oh he's trying to he's
trying to up his hood car salad card
these are [ __ ] physician absolu
but you wouldn't think that yeah that's
not the first thing you think it's funny
cuz lead tours comedians me Tony
Doughboy into here right so people I
can't even tell you how many times white
people would see us in the airport or
restaurant me or you guys football
players look at my body do I look like a
professional athlete are you guys in the
NBA the NBA that boy is 300 pounds what
about us looks like we are professional
athletes we can't figure it out it's
like what are you guys doing on the
plane and so I'm Diamond on Delta so I'm
always in first class why don't be like
this is the first class line yes you
know that's why I'm standing in it yeah
because I'm flying first class and I
mean alright get on it this time oh I
didn't know cuz you just assumed that
you shouldn't be here and that's the
thing about why people like people are
like all white people racist that's not
true
yeah right but what happens is a lot of
people are okay with you doing whatever
you do as long as it makes sense that
you should be doing it but you can fly
on the plane but you shouldn't be in
first class yeah that's where do you but
it and it usually is mostly white people
so when people are doing stuff out of
the ordinary that's when it feels weird
the whole Trayvon Martin things like
well that you are you walking with a
hoodie in this neighborhood you don't
belong here and that's what it is it's
it's the why people feel there's this
whole article that was going viral like
have you ever the title is have you ever
noticed why people never move out your
way like on the street and it was like
all these people like yeah like it's
like I should I belong here and I'm
gonna walk and if you were in my way
then you should move and a lot of this
stuff is subconscious because you know
to be white is to feel like you belong
here any people shouldn't sit on your
way it's that my friend told me that the
annoying thing about me he goes new and
then the most and this is when I was in
Sacramento oh yeah whenever you see a
white person on the sidewalk he goes you
purposely don't move out their way right
you know I don't because of that [ __ ]
yeah big cuz I always had to move out of
their way yes that's so [ __ ] funny
you said that me just had that
conversation last week goes he goes I
know for a fact when we walk on a
sidewalk we're not the ones moving out
the way cuz you refused I was like I
refuse right because why why not always
do it why and people will go ahead and
we think it's polite yeah but you're
kind of trained to like well you know
let me just get out the way and a lot of
times and it's
fine if everybody does that but this
group of people they don't seem to play
by those rules as much as everybody else
does yeah and they don't even realize it
a lot of times like I didn't even know
like minorities we be knowing why people
better than they know and that's why I
hate the whole like go back to your
country thing yeah people say to
minorities because I feel like
minorities love America more because we
see it for what it really is yeah it's
not the same for everybody else so the
fact that we love it and we criticize it
comes from a place of love not we want
to leave and may you brought us here
religion dance isn't freaking Egypt you
saw we did leave us alone
it's crazy go back I've never been there
go back to your country it's like they
don't want us there here they don't
[ __ ] African people hate people rah
for real though I don't religion no they
do not rock with African American AZ
muddy focus exactly yeah they over here
in this country they think that they
could do whatever they want exactly not
playing around
yes I this conversation with my friend
Amanda she was telling me like when she
first came here like she heard a lot of
stuff about kind of the stereotypes with
black people and maybe for her and maybe
it's cuz her parents better that stuff
too she goes yeah I don't understand
what the big deal but they don't know
about system it's just like systemic
like oppression it's not they just see a
lazy person
we're gonna go wall cuz African people
from what I've heard from African
friends in mind they consider themselves
immigrants not black people right we're
immigrants yes you know and we had that
immigrant hustler mentality absolutely
and a lot of times they do yeah because
when you come from another country to
America you've left everything behind
like I gotta make it and that hustle is
not over there we were talking about
this off-camera like people who come to
LA to make it often work harder than
people who are born and raised in LA
because they can always go into mom's
house and their cousin stuff if you
ain't from here it's either make it or
you got to go back home you and a lot of
times you get like when I moved here I
had rented my house out in Washington my
parents lived in North Carolina
full house like it's either make it here
or no plan B like you gotta make it so
that hustle mentality is even two or
three times ten times harder if you're
an immigrant like
you gotta hustle cuz I'm not going back
there like you gonna make it my kids
gonna make it and y'all better be a
doctor lawyer engineer yeah nothing in
between I always said this to African
people are so [ __ ] similar to Asian
people it's unreal
the way they beat their kids yeah
negative reinforcement but she believed
in me yeah like Asian pears and African
prayers like do y'all love like you can
never be good enough people be so
surprised man like I tell these stories
I remember when I went to college and we
were sharing like family stories
remember and mind you I grew up around
mainly black and Asian people yeah and
so when we would share stories of our
family they'd be like yeah like my
parents with a gift said they would send
me to my room I was like to do what
they're like send me to my room like for
what like what like what would happen
happen oh they was they would just may
send me to my room I had to wait there
like yet for what like what's happening
man so what are your parents does I do
my bed through an office chair my head I
was 6 years old
literally through an office chair at my
head once and just hit me upside my head
he used to [ __ ] you hit you he do he's
the WWF stopped me to the floor like
he'll to the head you might not used to
do this funny ass [ __ ] it was funny to
me now and that funny Ben right he used
to stick out his fists right and he was
never to punch myself in the face he
would go hit yourself you would and I
would sit there and I would try to
lightly tap my face like ah dad he goes
nope
you better pull for sit so I would have
a head but my foot like I'm telling you
he had some creative [ __ ] that is
reverse abuse you punch yourself exactly
and hard as you deserve it my dad used
to beat me so [ __ ] bad man cuz I
think that was a good thing for me
because I remember growing up in my
neighborhood you know people used to
bully each other a lot so I would get
beat by an adult so when I would get
fight with kids it didn't hurt as mad
nothing so nothing compared to what your
mom does oh for sure yeah it's crazy
story - I told I remember one time you
know those commercials where they had
those kids who uh it's like it was like
this black and white commercial in this
kid his dad comes up brings up his hand
a child abuse you don't have to take it
and I saw that commercial I was like I
don't have to take it I don't have to
take this and I got this [ __ ] wild
idea in my head I remember my day I
forgot what the argument was about what
my dad was about to hit me
and I was like you hit me I'm called
child services on you that's child abuse
oh my god stops he leaves the room and
in my mind I'm like I won right [ __ ]
face he comes back with a lead pipe oh
my god
swings it and I ducked and he shatters
the shelf behind me and he looks him he
goes that's child abuse yo your dad is
out of control
that's like that was my dad I thought
when people tell me they used to get
beat I was like did you really I mean I
got beat but your stories are inside
memories I tried that my mom like I'm
gonna call 9-1-1 she was like you better
call the police and the ambulance go to
jail ambulance for you police for me I'm
not gonna call oh I got beat with like
you know hanger is extension cord a
hanger switch the phone cord phone core
was probably the worst one the part that
plugs into the wall yeah cuz it's thin I
was like oh it's tan it's not gonna hurt
man that was sores but a lead-pipe you
know what the worst one was it was the
bamboo stick I'm not your [ __ ] line
yeah you know every asian kid knows
about these green bamboo sticks that
used to hold up plant yeah yeah so I
remember my grandma used to beat me with
this so everybody in the family beat me
dude it was it was like that's how we
grew up they were just tag team you know
your parents they could beat you and
your parents would then beat you for
someone else thank you like oh you out
here embarrassing the family wait till I
get home that's exactly what it was
so my grandma remember she used to beat
me with this little thin little bamboo
stick right the crazy thing about that
[ __ ] was it was so light like a
croissant yeah that [ __ ] that [ __ ] was
so quick because you could hear it but
you couldn't see it yeah and then you
don't know what happened and there's
like a two second delay and then you
just arch your back real quick I
remember the day that she hit me with it
and it broke and I got so happy right it
was like I beat the last boss and Mario
I was like that shit's dying I will
never get beat by that [ __ ] ever this
evil sadistic [ __ ] behind the [ __ ]
couch she had like a 36 pack and that
[ __ ] was so all sweat
and thus came out like Indiana Jones
actually whipped out a fresh one
that [ __ ] was bright green as [ __ ] like
a lightsaber this [ __ ] beat me with
that thing so you got in trouble cuz you
broke her cuz I'll blow you break my
good one I broke the good one
with my face I've been meaning to break
this one anyway everybody used to beat
my ass man [ __ ] [ __ ] suck and my
brother barely got beep Oh
cuz my sister was like that too yeah we
took I took cuz uh we a lot of times
they beat us in order my older brother
me by the time I got to her they're like
oh man forget it man she's a little girl
one bit like y'all had plenty of energy
for me and my brother but I remember my
dad beat me one time to my toes like
locked up like that right he beat me
then he came back in I'm like still
waiting for it don't unlock he's like
and just so you know that was 26 lashes
all right oh my god you thought I lost
count
we know I'm currently at Oh Caesar and
you want to let me know I got you 426
anybody [ __ ] funny more abused you
know that right for sure man and I'm
specially by today's standards oh we
rebuke I mean there's no way in my mind
I'm thinking that's not child abuse
right like how I always like to frame it
for people is you know when you're when
you don't have a lot of money I don't
got a lot of time and you got kids
you're the only way you know how to
discipline your child is in the quickest
way possible
alright my god that is right
revolutionary thought yeah cuz that is
true my mom worked two three jobs my dad
- how much time do they had to sit down
and say hey the reason why you can't do
this they don't have the time money is
tight they're freshmen and you know when
money's tight you're stressed the [ __ ]
out you don't even know why you're in a
bad mood
yeah just everything and by the way when
my parents when the money wasn't good
and they would fight more often yes so
they're their inner marital relationship
is terrible you know these kids that are
acting up they just know that they don't
want the kids to be a [ __ ] up and I
gotta fake this real quick before I hit
my other job David that is that is
revolutionary thinking like that is
scientific thinking cuz that is so true
cuz now I'm in a better position and it
takes more time to to raise a child
without hitting them because you have to
explain it they got question
you gotta give them leeway and stuff
like that my parents thought I brought
I'm tired mm-hmm I'm frustrated already
and you're here doing something I told
you already
okay yeah it's gonna be a great time I
had a terrible day at work anyway this
is stress relief cuz ain't no time for
therapy and hot cocoa
ain't no hate I remember a full house
bro I remember like Michelle and them
would do stuff and the piano would come
on and Danny would get on one knee like
listen slugger this is why you can't do
that to me where's the piano in my life
I know where the piano is on top of my
head because they [ __ ] smash that
[ __ ] over my face that's what the [ __ ]
the keys were and the keys came up now
it's like a [ __ ] Acme cartoon that's
where the piano I really do empathize
with my parents now now that I'm a lot
older BJ I don't have the resources that
we had no and and the best thing that I
like to put it too even in when in terms
of education so people say oh well I
might have they might have grown up in a
similar financial situation as we're
like growing up but they go well so
we're the same I was like we're not the
same because growing up the reason why
you understood is because you understood
how the education system worked you
understand all the stuff yeah my parents
did it and I didn't know right in order
for me to get into college I had to
figure that [ __ ] out for myself my
parents didn't know right how to get me
into college yeah I didn't know about
scholarships they didn't know about what
your grades would do talking to the
teacher after after-school program this
is all stuff that we had to figure out
our selfs and that's the advantage that
people have if they are second or third
generation in this country right I
didn't get to have or if your parents
didn't go to college yes these are the
things that we did my parents in a girl
in my neighborhood I know to change has
this you got a rapper go to the league
and like the only way I knew of like
people going to college was was
scholarship athletic scholarships like
black we didn't have him like when I got
to college man like I knew I was poor my
whole life but there was they became
readily apparent when I went to college
act Li and I'm like well you got
brand-new laptops and cars and they got
the maximum dorm money on their lunch
car they parents I mean some of these
kids have never even wash their own
clothes
like I remember this funny store I was
in the financial aid office trying to
get it trying to get it
change and this mom was putting all this
money on her son's like you know little
college car you pay for your food and
stuff and she was like well who's gonna
you know she noticed we had like a
7-eleven in our dorm you could buy like
burritos and soda and ice cream you know
I've been in Jerry's whatever she was
like I noticed they have like ice cream
for sale all day and it was a student he
was like yeah you know it's like
7-eleven
kids love and he was like she was like
who's gonna stop him from eating ice
cream for breakfast and the kid was like
I'm sorry she's like this card he can
buy anything he wants at any time and
they're like yeah well what if he wants
asking for breakfast who's gonna stop
him in the shoe the kid was like he's my
18 he doesn't know by now he shouldn't
eat ice cream for breakfast then he's
gonna get a stomachache I guess and I'm
thinking like your kid don't know that
you shouldn't eat ice cream for
breakfast and these kids really didn't
know like most of people in my class
freshman fell out not because they
weren't smart because somebody was
always reminding them do this turn this
in do this at this time and people
they're not used to waking themselves up
in my family my mom's like at like in
fifth grade so I'm not finding me
washing your clothes yeah this is how
you do whites this is how you do colors
you better wash them dry them fold them
hang them up whatever and she literally
stopped and that was like ten we were
cooking dinner 12 13 no babysitter
there's nobody gonna come we're leaving
we'll be gone for a couple of weeks
there's bread and water survive so when
I got to college I was like I bet I've
been doing all this stuff on my own wake
myself up get ready to go and I thought
everybody did that people would money
bro they're not they don't have to worry
about that stuff do they be saying some
wild [ __ ] I remember some some basic
[ __ ] threw me off they're like so where
do you go on vacation I'm like what's
that
you know vacation like when you take a
break I'll say what's that but you need
a break break what it was like some
basic [ __ ] I had no idea what the [ __ ]
they were saying they're like vacation
yeah what are you talking about racing
home summer homes the Hamptons like what
are your timeshare rich people sure time
cuz what you saying right now man I used
to make this junk on my old standard
said I was like you know I remember back
in the day when I first went to college
I was recording my people like I was on
a safari cuz I had no idea what the [ __ ]
my people did I was like damn these
[ __ ] they just they they buy
appetizers
like what the [ __ ] like usually it's the
meal and a glass of water and then
you're trying to debate whether you add
a tip or not yeah you should be happy to
and nouns like grown-up pours you should
be happy with everything you should be
happy for this food whatever it is
rice-a-roni every day you should be
thankful cuz a kid in africa as my mom's
whole thing kid in Africa doesn't happen
and I'm like what is it parent in Africa
telling that kid oh sure Hinata mean so
you should that's the whole thing and
that's tough growing up like that way
and then raising kids like now I'm
trying not to like pass that on and then
you're stuck with like I was taking my
kids on vacation in Hawaii in Maui which
was more expensive than even Honolulu
yeah right I'm looking at the broom
service bill and my oldest son is mad
he's like I'm like what's up man why are
you upset he's like my friends are there
at the Santa Monica Pier today I'm like
hold bodyslam like I just had a leave
because I was like you are in this at
this point this is a most expensive
vacation even I've ever been on
yeah and you talk about the Santa you've
been in the Santa Monica Pier 300 times
what are you yeah imma get right back
with you cuz that was soaked me because
as a kid we weren't even allowed to like
say our feelings yes say our thoughts I
do is joke about my said like if my mom
was driving down a one-way street and an
18-wheeler was coming I'd be like what
she must want us to die I would not dare
correct her like yeah we'll just dive in
and in heaven I I still won't correct it
I'll be like I don't know god yeah just
sheer fear and my kids don't have that
so trying to learn how to raise kids
without hitting them without beautiful
things though about that and the type of
relationship you have with your kid on
the flip side is the fact that he's open
and honest with you yes because the
other thing what fear breeds is that
that honesty disappears absolutely cuz
they're always afraid of getting in
trouble so the first thing they think
about is lying exactly so the great
thing is like your kid actually say some
stupid [ __ ] like that
I mean pockets make this right as long
as it's honest though at least he's
talking about the thing like I remember
I saw this meme that was like this is
good it's like I'd rather my kid get in
trouble and say oh my god I've got to
tell my dad instead of oh my god I can
tell my dad yeah like that doesn't mean
I'm gonna be proud of you or anything
like that but I'd rather you be able to
tell me let me learn how to grow
pregnant or you know whatever the case
is then to be like I can't even talk to
my dad about this stuff like he'll
he won't even understand that's how my
parents were just like Bridal y'all
don't even want to know the stuff that
we're thinking about because you won't
yeah my dad was so this one would say
some lying ass [ __ ] he'd be like hey if
you just tell me the truth you would
never get hit I would tell him the truth
I get my ass beat I'm like you should
have what what is this
either way either way I'm getting mad he
probably thought that yeah the truth is
so upset he's like I have I know what I
said like what you do listen I stab
somebody and this is he goes ok I gotta
kill you if I can't I can't do this I
gotta [ __ ] kill you I was a trouble
child so my brother was really good at
school and I wasn't you know it's so
funny that your kid was like oh God my
friends aren't the first of all you're a
black child at the Santa Monica Pier
that should not happen the first place
you suppose go to Long Beach what the
[ __ ] are you saying right now Santa
Monica Pier wrong with you only people
that are black there are [ __ ] dancing
on the pier and you over there for fun
and shut the [ __ ] up what's wrong with
you it's we don't have a lot of stuff
that you don't their perspective is flip
ya and it's a blessing but at the same
time like I don't have kids yet but what
I'm ready for kids is kind of like okay
how do I get this kid to understand that
what you have is a blessing that's why
for me right cuz I grew up it's just my
father was a pastor oh really and I was
a youth nurse for a couple years - yeah
there you go man Sinan mouths I got a
evil mouth and I got Christian ideals
right but when I was just just looking
at that I think like I want my kids to
grow up at a church and the reason why
even I'll tell this to if you guys
aren't religious having kids go to a
church the reason why is because it
teaches you community yeah it teaches
you that there are bigger things outside
of what you do right number three
there's free daycare on Sundays it's got
a bunch of damn kids
and then before this free food there's
mission trips yeah it's really really
helped open my eyes as an individual
where I had to go to Mexico when I had
to go to Tijuana and then build these
homes and be with these people
I really ain't [ __ ] yeah it helped me
out of the perspective is out of this
world yeah because you think your
problems are bad and I saw this other
thing on the Internet's like everybody
through their problems down on the
ground you pick yours back up because
you see what other people are dealing
with and stuff you like we don't have
potable water or potable water I'm not
to pronounce it then use like man my
kids are at the other friends are at the
beach like well you really don't have
problems like that but inside your own
little bubble it's like the worst day
ever this is the worst thing that could
be happy you know I saw this I saw this
video I'll show you it later
and mind you I met this girl we actually
did a video together she's a very very
sweet girl but me watching her insta
story made me realize how how privileged
she is in her own life and she doesn't
even realize it
now I'm saying it in a nice way right
what I want to say is how much of a
little [ __ ] you are but that's just how
I am that's not an insult to her she's
just a victim of her own circumstance
right so she went very once again I
gotta say this very sweet girl and I
love this girl to death but watching
that video maybe want to throw something
really hard so she went to Spain on a on
a vacation trip of some sort with her
husband which is already amazing right
and when they're having a good time she
tried to jump on his back she fell over
as she cracked her tooth hilarious right
so and my thing was when she put up that
thing on her instant story I thought she
was trying to tell us the funny stories
like you know I cracked my tooth but if
you watch this insta story she's you
know she goes there and she goes you
know I just want to say that she starts
crying oh my god she goes I took my
smile for granted and I just I never
knew what it was like to not have a
tooth for two days and I know it doesn't
seem like a big deal but I feel like the
universe is testing me and I'm my
universe is testing you could you broke
your own tooth that's what I'm saying
and so I don't know how to deal with
this she has crazy fans too cuz I you
know but you you got Taylor so she has
like Taylor Swift fans like I said I'm
not downplaying that whatever happened
to you was bad but in my mind that
happens to a lot of people and they
don't have health care they don't have
chip is just there to lose just chip now
yeah
that's just life now but exactly sing it
now they're just walking around with a
whistle for her it's like you are in a
position to the point where you've got
to go on vacation to Spain which for
sure it was a business of first-class
ticket then after your tooth chip you
had enough money to fly immediately back
to LA then get your tooth fixed the day
of and then you're gonna do this video
and say my life is hard
come on and huh it's hard for me listen
to that is you you really that the
perspective of that you really have no
idea most people are like this podcast
is brought to you by bombas bombas
bombas BAE BAE so when I was at school
the cool and the hot thing was gel pens
pokeyman cards some Yugi O's and beyond
that sports and basketball and all that
other sports and basketball hip hop
paraphernalia son listen if you were
cool you had it and if you didn't have
that stuff you were not cool well guess
what's cool now son
bum Baz and they bring out all the Envy
on the schoolyard which isn't really all
that surprising because they're the most
comfortable comp of the pull kids socks
ever
they're colorful literally bursting with
color they even have a little colorful
beyond them and comfortable so
comfortable they're designed with
several comfort innovations that help
them and make them feel better than any
kids socks ever made so send your kids
back to school with the socks that keep
them comfy and colorful and ready to
take on the school year and let me tell
you some sis-boom-bah donates a pair of
socks for every purchase you should get
yourself some to tell you some I'm a
cool kid I'll wear bomba socks if I'm
not discussing you with my feet right
now boom my socks is blessing my feet
and making sure that none of y'all see
my nasty little toes and I'm telling you
right now everybody loves my bone my
socks they like well you get that socks
I'm like Bamba son boom box baby you
know it's all about the bomb bus yo so
check it out
visit Baba's calm / brain and get 20%
off your first purchase that's B om bas
calm / brain for 20% off your first
purchase bombas dot-com / brain get on
and get dim socks
be cool be poppin and show people what's
up
cuz ain't about the style always on the
tops sometimes it's about the style on
the bottom and bombas got you baby
exact you get on a plane like some
people only trip is watching other
people yeah hey trips yes I be seeing
people do suffering like bro like
specially back when I had nothing like
bro y'all be living live people don't
know man
you only know about the world from your
perspective yeah and sometimes people
clown me cuz I go to Hawaii every year
right yeah yeah like for me I always I
never went on vacation my parents don't
go on vacation yeah they don't go on
vacation so much they don't like
vacation really you know like they're
missing out on work they just they just
it feels uncomfortable for them to leave
their home that's how much fit they went
on their very first vacation to Hawaii I
think it was six years ago was for the
first time in their life they ever went
on vacation and it was weird for them
you know what I mean yeah so I look at
it from a perspective like that
also - because we're creators we get to
create our own destiny and it's a
blessing to do what absolutely it is a
blessing because if it wasn't this I
definitely would probably be dead or be
like doing some depressed yeah I'd be
smoking crack for sure dude instantly
then I'd be on a podcast talking to a
crackhead it's like was it like babe one
little universe flip right absolutely
man that's true so when I see a video
like that like I said I'm not I'm not
dogging on the fact that she probably
felt bad cuz she chipped her tooth she's
a beauty guru you're I get it but I
think most people would see that and
maybe like oh [ __ ] I chipped my tooth
and laugh about it and move on yeah but
the fact that you could put up a video
and say hey the universe is teaching us
that is absurd it's absurd yeah
absolutely
a lot of her fanbase will disagree with
us and that's understandable but for me
it's like I got to always tell myself
that my glass is half-full absolutely
and I think that's why I appreciate
growing up poor yeah cuz I was a member
of being Warren Buffett said that he
said the most important factor in
becoming rich is growing up poor cuz
that hunger and lack remote like I I
work now like I have not made a dime oh
you specifically do
when do you not put a content when I
watch you I feel like a piece of [ __ ]
and it's supposed to be the other way
around black dude like damn you work too
hard we bring stereotypes I feel like if
I tell my wife and my friends be like
fam like it's okay and I but I've seen
creators who take breaks and they like
the algorithm forgets them oh they're
gone right it's tough so I'm like I
cannot stop I like I won't stop until I
have made enough where if I took a
year-long break all my income would
would sustain me because they make
creating in this world like you you and
you need to take breaks like I've kind
of calmed down when I go on vacation
like I only post stuff that like maybe I
got for my story or whatever like I I
realized that I don't have to post every
day but like growing up or like
everybody worked my mom my dad like I
have friends who didn't their first job
they had even had a job yet in college
like man I was working under the table
at 13 and my first job was I was like
bussing tables out for a wedding caterer
getting paid cash 13 14 years old yeah
official job I had like when I was a kid
I had a candy business like to buy I see
little military bases buy candy on base
for like 30 cents sell it for a dollar
off base that's cool yeah I had a lawn
mowing company like in order to get it
my parents my bro and no extra money you
want shoes fam you better sell drummers
work get a work for me like I work so
it's hard to turn that off you know I
mean even when I'm on my case I'm like I
got to put a bit like always feel like I
got to put a bit like I haven't posted a
video yet today and I'm like searching
on Twitter like well I gotta find
something funny if I don't don't forget
me and it's just like rah got podcast
coming out today I'm shooting this
podcast I'm shooting another podcast at
5:30 like I'm literally shooting content
all day and I feel like I haven't done
anything about see that's that's the
amazing thing about you right is that I
always see your stuff I'm like he he is
constantly in everybody's face which is
a good thing right yeah and the crazy
thing is about you it's like I always
say sometimes people hold things that
they hold things that they think are too
precious they go this isn't perfect yet
about it being perfect bring go it's not
about it you'll never be satisfied there
oh and that was my biggest problem right
because my thing was like oh if I gotta
make
these amazing shorts and whatever yeah
and I started [ __ ] up that way
because nothing was ever good enough and
I stopped putting things out yes which
is stupid a lot of creators have that
like there's been so many times I posted
a video and then like the top three
comments are funny jokes that are
funnier than anything I put in there and
I'm just like and you can't have it back
but I actually what I do is I shoot and
post before I can think too much about
it yeah because I realized the more I
think about I'm not last not funny
enough and and also what's helped is a
lot of stuff that I don't think it's
funny
goes crazy viral yeah so I'm just like
man what do I know you never know what's
gonna go viral so I just think create
edit post going about my day yeah and
then just let the internet do what the
Internet's gonna do like you never know
what you're gonna that's gonna happen
like that so and it's so refreshing to
hear that [ __ ] to cuz I got to him I had
this weird [ __ ] habit if I when
something does really well I'm like I'm
done with it let me try something new
just so [ __ ] stupid
right cuz I'm like all my friends do
this [ __ ] they go yo you did this thing
it was poppin right like this thing
called carpool confessions I was doing
it it was this type of style stuff yeah
it was funny conversations in a car and
we would just just chop it up right it
really well averaging like 400,000 views
per video right and I did it for like
maybe two months and I got I'm done with
this I moved on and everybody what are
you doing and I was like I'm bored and I
moved on and so even for me I used to do
these like vlogs right we just talk [ __ ]
all the time right I don't know if you
know how much of a David Soufan I just
same with just getting film you j-jake a
and tim i sat at my desk when i worked a
regular job hating my job and i watched
all you guys's videos so I'm acting like
I'm not a fan that's crazy I don't know
that sure I've been trying to meet you
for one time on the couch talking Adorno
like he got the black the black love
where's the intro so you having your
vlogs were like when you switch over to
genius brain I was like ah like I got it
I got totally got as a creator but I was
like that was some of the world's
greatest content like but I can tell
from the stop it that's that takes a lot
of work it does like you know thinking
the the script writing the editing
that's not just like I gotta go off the
top of the dome that's one of the reason
it's easy for me I just make it real
quick and post it but you were
pudding-like time joke joke joke thought
anonyme editing all this stuff into it
timing music so I can see how that can
be more taxing and you know cuz it's
funny cuz I'm actually gonna go back to
doing that not because is because it
started becoming fun for me again ya
know so like I took a break from it now
because I got all these damn thoughts
where I just had no where to put it and
like hey bro go do your damn videos
again other reason why I stopped doing
it was because I started putting into my
standard and I was like oh understood
it's like what want you to put this yeah
but you can do both exactly you can do
both yeah [ __ ] up on him like this cuz
you did that joke here doesn't mean you
can't put so much of my videos have
influenced my stand up and stand up and
flow into my videos like and and people
will a lot of times not even the same
people gonna consume it like who comes
with the club or whatever and even if
they do it's a different version it's
really different it's a different
version you have the live energy of the
crowd all that type of stuff but I get
it on a creative sense you feel like
those are separate world yeah but it's
really just your creative engine yeah
and sometimes that goes into podcast
sometimes a book sometimes stand-up
sometimes they can go into all all three
if I write a book I'm gonna have some of
the stories from my stand because they
say you really make me feel like I
[ __ ] up because I kept reading these
comments and they're like you'll go back
to your visit what are these kids know
now you say it I'm like [ __ ] well the
internet will try to box you in though
yeah like if you give them one thing
that they like they don't want you to
change anything when it has a creator
that gets boring I'll tell you some of
the funniest [ __ ] it's sad but it makes
me laugh too is I'll do a regular video
like every now and then I'll do a
regular video I put it up it's like a
thousand followers go up in that day and
I put a podcast up I lose 200 followers
I'm like yes stupid sons of [ __ ] do
you really hate this [ __ ] don't you guys
I I don't cuz the people who [ __ ] with
me [ __ ] with it heavy yes but a lot of
people miss that advice to the camera
type of [ __ ] right right that's what
that's a thing like people sometimes
they subscribe for that and that alone
and I [ __ ] it up I'm sorry guys look
the podcast is great cuz look I got cam
on yeah man I'm here look at me David to
my friends I love I love your videos
don't married you it's so like I said
it's just so off the top and it could
you could literally talk about anything
and everything which I really [ __ ]
like it was funny though I have a fear
of running out of material I'll you'll
never do first four videos and even more
videos I'm
okay because the internet it's always
giving but for stand-up I'm like ma'am
what if I run out of stuff to talk about
but the Internet in the world like I've
noticed like if you ever notice instead
of comedians later in their career it's
not as much original material and it's
almost all current events and I realize
like if you have a viewpoint of the
world people just want to hear you yeah
like what's your point of view and
that's what me and you can make a video
on the same exact topic and it'll be two
different videos and our audience will
enjoy the like I want to hear if you
have a true audience member they're like
I don't care if everybody else in the
world talked about it I want to hear
David all I want to hear is keV like I
want to hear their point of view even if
it's similar because they like your
voice and I think that's one of the
benefits of doing this is people work I
want to hear how you think about this
that's why people thought we should pail
so much man
yes I'm always waiting for Chappelle's
spin on [ __ ] and you know I was so happy
you watch the Chappelle did I just watch
her two days ago that [ __ ] was [ __ ]
crazy so I remember cuz he was talking
about how he was making fun of how like
because I did the same [ __ ] in a
stand-up set right he just he just
frames it a lot better but it was just
like the weirdest part of that Michael
Jackson documentary was the fact that
literally Michael Jackson jacked off to
[ __ ] wait Rob mrs. butthole and I
thought that [ __ ] was the most hilarious
thing I ever heard in my life
it's like hey don't touch me you stay in
that corner let me check off to the
[ __ ] stinks the eye of the Sphinx was
hilarious right but sometimes Dave
Chappelle says [ __ ] that I can't get a
little no I think only the thing is at
this point he's already paid yep like
he's got paid for that special so you
cannot can't I think this whole cancer
culture thing is really interesting like
that we love to stop people from doing
whatever like the Internet does not
allow you to grow that person you can't
make mistakes you can't think you like
you need to know everything right now
everything you should know about the
world so Dave Chappelle is like he went
the whole other way with that yeah like
instead of saying I don't know if I want
to step on toes he was like I'm gonna
step on every single toe that exists the
stuff nobody's talking about I'm gonna
make fun of Michael Jackson and
pedophilia and gay people and
transgender people and I'm like I
watched the special just like like give
a [ __ ] he didn't care so much it's like
can't you even cancel him yeah he
doesn't care
he doesn't kiss please he's flipped it
on its head and being like you clicked
on my face like that was the thing
though like you already know from his
last three specials you know what he's
talking about if you still came to watch
this to be upset who do you have to
blame you don't have to choose to watch
me and I feel like that was really like
refreshing because you feel like there's
a lot of stuff you can't talk about and
they remind you you can talk about
whatever you want and somebody and a lot
of people like secretly like is how I um
got elected people like I'm not voting
for him but yeah you know they went in
that little thing and you were like
people were like all my boys I did you
see it did you see yeah talk about it
people were laughing in their room they
don't want to admit on Twitter or
Instagram that they like those jokes
because you know we all have like a
version of ourselves that we want people
to think we are but sometimes at home
you just want to laugh at some super
dark stuff and that's what that [ __ ] was
I mean I [ __ ] loved it that's why
sometimes when I watch you know what I
liked about because I saw a couple of
clips of your stand-up on Facebook right
I think what I liked about your stand-up
the best is because it's honest because
it's about the stuff that you grew up
with yeah you know what I mean and
nobody can take that from exactly nobody
can feel something that happened to me
yeah and my kid did this you can't steal
that yeah and still like black people be
like why people be like dating in LA
like that's a lot of you know parallel
thinking but the way my mom raised me
like your dad swinging let pipe at you
even though we all got beat growing up
the way we do we feel like that yeah so
that's a story if you frame it as a joke
I can't steal that yeah I'm not I mean
because that's that is a David Bing and
I feel like that's how that's how a
thing I'll be able to create forever is
because this is my life and Kevin Hart
said that he said you're you'll always
have your own life experiences in your
viewpoint yeah and if you never lose
that you'll never run out of material
you might not be able to go like and
that's another fear of mine like getting
progressively less funny because your
most stand-up specials are like the
first ones the best because you've been
freaking working that for years since
you some of those jokes to like Madol
that first special that i only release
to the public is still for sale these
jokes have been worked since I started
like some of those jokes were my first
time I did stand-up they've been
perfected and you just don't have the
same amount of time in between I was
like ten years of jokes and now I've got
like a two months to come up with the
next one and then I go on tour next year
it's two months like
obviously they're not gonna be as good
because that was the best same thing
with artists usually people's first
album is best several Beyonce hers
getting progressively better but most
people they get they go down down down
and hope you had some hits it'll search
three albums cuz most people out the
first three albums they don't have that
much fun no more
like we go back to that life experience
thing you're super important I think
sometimes when I watch stand-up a lot of
people who want to do stand-up they
sound like they're trying to do stand-up
yes and I think the best part about the
the stand-up that I like anyways I'm not
like this connoisseur that gets to I'm
not I'm not like a [ __ ] psalm on Yale
[ __ ] stand up I like the [ __ ] word
just sounds like that person's talking
to you yes you know it's just that's
that person it's I hate it when it
sounds like a setup and I know that it's
coming and it ruins the magic for me
absolutely that's what Dave Chappelle
does so well you don't know when his
punchlines are coming no because it's
just the conversation it's just and you
don't even when I was watching on I felt
like I forgot I was watchin Stan yeah
until the punchline I'm like uh he kind
of lulled me to sleep with the setup and
you forget he's telling the joke until
he hit you with the punchline and that's
when I remember I was watching one we
talked about he did his jokes backwards
and I was watching my like I probably
never be that good yeah I just have to
accept that that's what it finally feels
like to be an MBA and watch LeBron play
like I mean we're playing the same sport
yeah but he's just in a different league
than me like I might be an all-star but
I'm not I'm not greatest of all time and
I feel like that and that's okay yeah
you can still have a lot of fun make a
lot of money doing that but he's
operating at a different level than how
did you get in the stand-up when did
that start interestingly enough I
started when I was 16
I'll say me that's good yeah 16 my first
show was at a church same here yeah
really yeah a church a talent show and
my brother was a I was I'm outta my
brother like I think I'm gonna try
standup means like man this girl that
that we knew was like she don't think
you're funny cuz she know that like that
took me from thinking about it to doing
it and then like three or four years ago
he was like oh yeah she never actually
said nothing
I just knew if I told you that it would
make you you would make sure that Wow
to prove her wrong so yeah I did in
church in high school and then in
college and then I got fired from
working in the bank in 2009 and that's
when I started going like
super hard like I was a terrible
employee like I will only time I use the
copy machine was to print up color
pictures of my comedy show flyers that's
Dell so one time I left a color one in
the originals part and my manager like
hey what's this sounds like my show
tickets but I got you yeah you're on my
list feels like no you shouldn't be
using this for that all right
oh you right actually this is the bank I
shouldn't be doing that so once I got
fired I was a hard I gotta make it
happen now you don't say so
so yeah I've been doing pretty
consistently for 810 years now that's
amazing
yeah and it's a thing that you'd like
there's no speeding of the process in
standup you have to take the time
onstage because I think Andrew Schultz
said this stand-up is the collection of
a lot of micro skills it's public
speaking it's timing it's meeting an
audience it's it's gauging an audience
it's gauging the room it's it's it's
storytelling and some of that stuff you
just can't get without repetition of
like this how your percent and Andale
doesn't matter how long you've done it
if you took a fat break you could tell
this ring rust oh man that's why I can't
stop last year I did a I did a college
show and I hadn't understand it been a
year because I was focusing on film and
stuff yeah I still got my oh [ __ ]
I got it was like halfway through the
set I forgot all my jokes I went Q&A
time guys like oh I haven't gone blank
in my head since I started and there's
been that long yes and so I just had to
flip it and just I should do a comedic
you today luckily it worked out but in
my mind I was like Joe and [ __ ] yeah you
thought you was you should not hide from
stand-up mm-hmm that's what Jerry
Seinfeld song he did this comedian cars
episode and somebody was asking how he
feels about Instagram and comedians and
all this and then like are you upset he
was like absolutely not and he's like
really why they don't respect this game
and he was like comedy always weeds out
the non funny for real you know one
lasts for a long time if they're not
really fun you will flame out especially
stand-up comedy like you're not really
funny
gimmicks gags brub you can get somebody
to pay once but because a lot of
influence was doing stand-up back on
Viners and stuff like they were
headlining and comedians were so man
like brother if you're not really good
people only only get the celebrity thing
first five minutes yeah you got 45
minutes you need to make me like nothing
it's not gonna be funny just because
you're up there I paid 60 bucks it was
interesting because when I did so be me
Bart and Joe booked the same show out in
Minnesota mmm swear this costume they
had a huge budget and so I had to do an
hour set and they did they they were the
openers for me oh and that was the first
time that they ever saw me do an hour
set yeah and I got lucky because I've
been working on an hour set for so many
years I never had the opportunity to
really do it yeah and so they were like
did you practice the set as I nope I was
like it might work out it might not and
so you know and I went out there they're
like yo your [ __ ] was good yeah saw 16
at that time non-stop yeah if I couldn't
do an hour set with since at that point
it was like eight years of experience
yeah [ __ ] suck you might want to do
something exactly
you know the show was great it did
really well yeah I think the reason why
I stopped doing stand-up was at a
certain point I made a shift into film
and that started making me happier yeah
so extendable I think as you get older
Stan you're standing just gets better
and better and absolutely especially cuz
you like I the only reason why I want a
kid right now so goes for my standard
material oh it's the best man like I'm
realizing like so many people always ask
me would you made it this far if you
were single I'm like absolutely not no
because my kids gave me so much material
one and they ground you cuz this
business man the bigger you are the more
people just tell you like we were
talking about earlier what you want to
hear well my kids don't care my kids do
not watch my shows no more I remember
like this tour my kids that watched like
we'll watch one show so we're in Philly
and we were at this kind of nice hotel
hey you guys going to the show and my
young is like you gonna do the same
jokes I was like yeah I mean yeah it's a
toy sight and we pulled out a cigarette
I've heard it all before
yeah so they don't care baby and it's
not funny to them the or so that is
really humbling and growling people like
Bob you I'm not came onstage at home
yeah I'm dad or I'm
Kevin you know my wife but they're not
impressed by any of that stuff and also
the other part of that is if I lost all
that they wouldn't care either way if I
just worked at Target my kids wouldn't
be trippin as long as I can still go
there soccer games and we still go watch
the movies they're not tripping about
that and I realize like that is so
important in this industry because
people you know Shannon chart was saying
this he's like fans like you saw Andrew
Luck got booed when he retired yeah like
that dude literally had like lacerated
kidneys and like going crazy injured and
the moment he's like I can't do this
anymore they boo you and Shannon Sharpe
was like that's the thing about a fan
they only they only blow when you're hot
yeah and if you ain't hot in the morning
like you can't he can't do anything for
them anymore
he can't help them win a Super Bowl he
can't get a first down he can't throw a
touchdown so now he's literally useless
to these people and there nope it
doesn't matter anymore with them anymore
right so you gotta have friends and
family who if I was literally useless
say I got cancelled and all my social
media got deleted I still gotta have
people who I can call for a barbecue and
they'll pull up even from just an uber
driver or work at Target and like that
is the grounding thing in my life my
family my kids that they ain't trippin
like this is a dope ride but if I lose
this they're not shipping and I feel for
you anyways just from looking at it from
an outside perspective it seems like
your your wife it has to be like a
strong rock in your life cuz you know
even for you being at a bank and getting
fired to say [ __ ] it I'm gonna go to
stand-up comedy that support it's such a
huge thing when you have somebody in
your corner saying you can do it yeah I
believe in you and they hold you up when
you're even for you when you doubt
yourself and you have somebody else it
helps so much David 100% right like
people don't even understand her value
like we always get into this cuz my boy
does boy he doesn't like when people get
divorced and the wife gets half even if
she'd been there the whole time he's
like we just basil she's like she you
know he gave her like half our it was
like crazy amount of money he's like why
and he's like she wasn't in there in the
room like bro you don't realize how much
support happens even if she's not
literally working at Amazon like when
you doubt yourself they're there when
you see like I think his wive actually
helped with business plan of Amazon but
my wife is like she be tagging my jokes
like the hard core like yeah you really
you're doing that joke a little
last two or three tags aren't working
the way you think they are yeah and you
could tighten this up and people are
like fans are not gonna do that you know
she'd be like I watched all of them like
I remember one joke I used to do when I
was young and I couldn't I brought it
back for my first tour last year yeah
and I couldn't get it to work man it was
cool but it was it used to be like a
closer yeah and she was like you're
missing the pacing that joke worked
because you hit it faster and it built
on itself and built on itself built on
itself you're you're dragging it out too
much so the next night I tried it and it
came right back and I was like bro
nobody in the world could give me that
note but her you know I'm saying cuz she
been there so that's why I it's it's
there's no you can't even put a dollar
amount on that type of value there's no
value you can put on believe in yourself
that's what I think Kanye lost like when
he lost his mom he's just like he lost
away he saw himself why he used to think
he was Superman when you lose that that
confidence everything else fails his
music fails the way sees the world fails
like all that at least from his point of
view it's not the same anymore cuz he
don't have the same confidence and
that's what my wife helps with like all
that and that's so admirable because I
feel for a lot of young people who live
in this very fast-paced world yeah you
kind of identify yourself with what
everybody else tells you that you are
yeah you don't have a strong foundation
to really ground your identity yes you
get [ __ ] up because you live and die
by your likes and your comments yeah at
the end of the day I even had a
conversation with my fiancee I told her
you know if if all else fails I'm okay
right we're okay
I'm good yeah this all this stuff is a
bonus I'm actually beyond where I
thought I would be at this age right
everything right now is a blessing and a
plus saw whipped cream and cherries yeah
you know I'm saying like and that's the
best when you don't feel like you would
have made it as far as like where I
could lose and you need that yeah like
you need to be able to lose it all
because if you don't you'll be
influenced to do stuff you shouldn't do
mm-hmm if you're not willing to lose it
off then you don't have it because
you're beholden to the comments likes
the the approval and stuff like that
like if a whole bunch of Greater start
doing one thing they're like like when
prank videos are going crazy I was like
I'm just not gonna prank stuff like it's
nothing even if that's what it takes
I just won't make it before I have like
I just like come on man because I
to live with that I gotta live with
myself and I'm just not gonna do that
like there's just certain stuff you got
to have your your moral compass on
straight or you'll just you'll fall for
anything I'm saying I couldn't I can't
look at myself in the mirror and know my
kids cuz my kids at the age where
they're watching my videos and stuff I
can't I can't put no trash up I don't
believe in like I had to and you have to
eat those words sometimes like when I
wasn't rocking with the NFL over the
Kaepernick stuff I had to really be a
man of my word
cuz they offered me a brand deal to do a
commercial for the NFL oh wow and I saw
the budget in the email you know they
never really put the budget in the first
reach out yeah it's like let's talk see
if you're interested they put the budget
in then I was like oh do I hate the NFL
because I don't know if at that price
you know I could do it and I was like
bro that is selling out yeah doing
something you don't believe in just for
money is selling out it's not like you
know on YouTube be member with back in
the day when Brandon's first came out
people are you selling now you got a
brand deal something that's not
something that's a selling selling out
is selling something you don't believe
in or you don't agree with for money
that's selling out that's what a lot of
kids don't think David you don't get
bran deals it's not that I don't get
brand deals
I can't peddle [ __ ] that I wouldn't use
exactly right so if you I have a beard
right now cuz I got a brand deal from my
I'll just say a very famous shaving
company yeah they're like you got to try
our new razor it's for african-american
skin you can shave your face with
because I never shaved my face with the
razor because black men usually I've
really seen some stopper knowledge stop
our razor bumps all that stuff and again
they sent me a crazy amount of money but
I was like I gotta test it out for real
and I tested it out and I could have
made the video the next day because my
skin was smooth and stuff like that but
I was like now let me wait a week to my
hair grows back and see but I got razor
bumps in mother [ __ ] bruh I was like and
they're like well you already sent a
video in you could just post it no you
[ __ ] me up man cuz then a dude even one
dude
one person buys it cuz I said it works
and he get razor bumps there's no amount
of money in the world that makes me feel
good about lying to someone for money
like my all I have is my credibility
yeah so I'm like nom and then the Lord
gave me a beer like it was a blessing
yeah cuz otherwise I would have never
saved my face cuz I'd let my beard grow
out to get rid of the razor bone
yeah and then I just kept it yeah but
that's what integrity would do but you
really gonna have to turn down some
money man you a good man and if L came
up to me I dropped my morals real fast
it's like okay stuff Stanley Kaepernick
and here's $30,000 listen to me captain
that piece of [ __ ] he's not doing
anything from his car to us this boy
doing [ __ ] for this country all right
him and his stupid-ass fro which by the
way he does not keep up well I was
sellout super fast like David you a
sellout yeah but look at him flip
[ __ ] I'll let you know that 30k
is not enough to sell out right a
million dollars is a different story and
I know for a fact my fans wouldn't even
hate me for it was like you're a sellout
but David is a million that's a little
different right right right
that's cool man I'm glad like you have a
lot of sensibilities that I see in
myself you definitely work a lot harder
than me though which kills me on the
inside but you guys own businesses you
know what your focus is and I really do
admire that [ __ ] like I said it's weird
because I don't have this thing where I
look at somebody success and it makes me
feel bad it motivates me right maybe so
I you know one of the biggest reasons
why I started following you was because
watching your videos motivated me it
reminded me not to hold things too
precious yes right because I'm watching
care if he's putting out these videos
every day about anything and everything
yes and even if at the time some of them
I'm like oh they weren't as good as his
last one but there was still something
that somebody found funny if that's all
it is and I feel like that you got to
understand what I go through and I'm
just like brother this is just yeah but
I realize like I'm out of myself after a
comic comic strips like I had some
favorite comic book strips Calvin and
Hobbes and some of them are just like
amazing like the best strips and some
Wednesday's yeah it wasn't as best but a
lot of times people just they're just on
their 10-minute break they just want
something a laugh at they don't really
care and as a creator you cannot
possibly have your best piece of
creative work every single time you
impossible it's impossible so it's
better to just be like man I'm gonna
just do this and then that man some of
the stuff be going viral like it's
frustrating as a creator to put out what
I think is really funny
like this is I put extra work into this
I actually wrote a script does nothing
me and my boys arguing about what chips
should be ranked freakin on the Today
show I'm like bruh I have had so much
better content been not Doritos fam ah
Fritos but it does it who are we to tell
you what what you enjoy oh you know what
speaking about that [ __ ] you did a video
on this because everybody was doing well
yeah but I didn't get to try it yet cuz
the lines are too [ __ ] long the
paparazzi is it that good is it good it
is that good better than the chick-fil-a
sandwich now the spicy one is better
than the chick-fil-a sandwich the
original one is on par but the spicy one
and I love chick-fil-a yeah that was
like there's no way
but the spicy one is legit better than
the chick-fil-a sandwich and I know I
know but I couldn't believe it
I've been trying to get one of those
goddamn sandwich sort out it's just I
can't get one there they're out missed
like Elmo's Furby mania people are like
why don't you do a video yeah because I
can't that's why I've been trying to
announce they sold out and they don't I
don't think they really sold out they
just put it a pause on it they can they
couldn't handle it yeah cuz you know
it's like that's an integrity thing to
Papa he's always had bad customer
service they never have the chicken
ready and now they released something
that's actually good they were not
prepared for that much influx of people
who was waiting for Church's Chicken to
come up in this [ __ ] cuz I I'm a
Church's Chicken till I [ __ ] die
really love Church's Chicken I grew up
with Church's Chicken
yes everywhere whatever so this is this
is the general rule of thumb for people
who don't go to like fast food fried
chicken spots KFC is everywhere white
neighborhoods Mexican neighborhood or
whatever Church's Chicken is only in a
black neighborhood and it is [ __ ]
delicious it is crispy as [ __ ] if you
don't [ __ ] with the Church's Chicken
honey they got the best biscuits in the
game
hands down hands down not even a
competition don't know Popeyes no KFC no
Red Lobster churches has the best
business in the game [ __ ] honey on
this year [ __ ] don't know no I
don't know cuz they ain't trying to go
they got bars on the windows anybody
really trying to trust that like I love
the
bars on the window best restaurants are
the ones we have to walk through the
kitchen in the bathrooms in the kitchen
fire this is some real [ __ ] so when I
shot this film I did it's called [ __ ]
mm-hmm
there was a in the spot that we were
shooting right next to it it was it was
in like south central yeah right next to
a church chicken I search his chicken
for breakfast and dinner for 21 days
straight not even [ __ ] lie to you I'm
not [ __ ] lie to you Haiti encourages
for breakfast because the moment that
they opened up is when we was shoot and
I would [ __ ] get a Church's Chicken
anything it would be chicken strips
biscuits whatever I would get that [ __ ]
instantly delicious you did not get
tired of that for three weeks I grew up
on this [ __ ] Wow that's my mom's
favorite fried chicken too oh really
yeah so my parents on a black beauty
supply store so that's why the blacks
can't get in they saw it and they were
like they bought in early and now we out
yo I remember this this [ __ ] argument
I got with the customer it pissed me off
so bad like number one she try to Jack
some [ __ ] and she try to get all
holier-than-thou on me right Oh hold on
show you just try to [ __ ] Jack a box
adjust for me and all of a sudden like
I'm the I'm the evil one you know I'm
saying how dare you not allow us all
this business that I could steal from
get a grown-ass person relax are you a
[ __ ] grown either you promotional
some [ __ ] the [ __ ] anyways she's like
still in this box adjust for me right
[ __ ] pissed she was like oh you
[ __ ] watch it because I'm black I'm
like I'm watching you because you stole
our [ __ ] what the [ __ ] are you talking
about when you actually are stealing
yeah you're not exactly I'm watching me
steal I mean yes that's the whole point
of running like did you not know this is
a black everybody's black what are you
talking about I was like if you're not
black you're the one I'm watching the
most is us does it because I'm black
it's because you're a thief yeah this is
the wildest [ __ ] he is so mad at that
[ __ ] makes no sense I was like 99% the
demographic is black yeah that's the
only people that come here so not cause
you're black is because you got a box of
relaxer in your jacket and you for some
reason thought I couldn't see it hey yo
get the [ __ ] out of here it's funny cuz
like as I got older I started getting a
mouth piece on me you know I started
talking back [ __ ] and they're just
like elements [ __ ] mean I'm
like your parents are a lot nicer it's
like no it's like the [ __ ] roast you
trust dude I'm talking about it's weird
because whenever I saw a white person
come in I'm like you do not belong here
right you're trying to steal there's
nothing in here but you're nothing in
you yeah no y'all don't be using
products like that you're looking at
s-curl you looking at looking at sulfur
ate like this stuff good like no black
people don't like sulfur aid you put
that [ __ ] down I worked at that store
day in and day out so for me for me like
identity was weird for me right yes I
grew up you know Asian immigrant but I
grew up in a predominantly black
neighborhood yeah so I just didn't know
where the [ __ ] I belong right right you
know what I mean I remember growing up
and every [ __ ] weekend Thursday
Friday and Saturday there was this truck
called moze moze would come up in a taco
truck in the whole neighborhood would
come out as a block the [ __ ] be
shooting dice next to my parents door
[ __ ] on a cardboard box that was the
weakest sound like are you getting a
hood movie I bet you're wondering how I
got here see that beauty supply store
that's my family I said this before
there was another a corner store to
which I didn't even know that the
courser just called liquor liquor school
right we used to call Punjab and and I
didn't know Pujols with a derogatory
term what we call this why not it was
poojas my whole life you know Amy a
person that worked there yep
and well I know you about to go to
Punjab so you don't we don't know these
[ __ ] because it's just a part of the
neighborhood nobody shooting dice in
front of our store was a normal [ __ ]
Absolut
right we had Lord Toni's artistic
fingers
that was next to our store the
[ __ ] went to jail you know for
doing some crazy [ __ ]
all areas yeah that was my upbringing
crony yeah I grew up in like the thick
of things right and it was such a like I
used to hate that experience growing up
because I think I compared my life to
other peoples when I went to college
yeah but then at the same time is
probably it's it's it's a reason why Who
I am today you know that is your core
programming yeah did you get a whole
bunch of you think you're black or you
ain't black are you you and Tim probably
led the league in that yes we got that
comment so consistently and I started
getting so [ __ ] mad yeah because even
for me when I was trying to get a job I
was trying to get rid of this this type
of twang I had in my voice even right
now I'm trying not to do it right it's
still there I don't hear it but other
people hear yeah yeah so they were
already trying to be black I'm like what
does that mean I don't know what that
means I'm just a product of my
environment yes if I grew up in a
predominantly black neighborhood
everybody spoke like this yep then how
what the [ __ ] am I supposed to do that's
how you that's how you all we are is our
relationship with other people yeah my
boy big R&J white dude big six eight
white grew up in a predominantly black
neighborhood predominate lack Church he
same problem like you trying to be like
the loves black women - he's like
brother this is all this is what my boy
said was fine this is what I this is
what's fine like this black girls like
white girls they smell funny right but
that's his whole he's the same thing
like and that's a different thing I feel
like like it's the whole Miley Cyrus
thing like she didn't grow up with it
and she tries to profit off of it and
they want to no longer serves her she
puts it back down yeah I feel like
that's what bothers black people but
it's who you are but I mean we embody we
are really like inviting oh for sure you
let why do you can dance you can hoop me
like oh snap like a white boy come on
like we're really loving like that but
just don't pick us up and put us down
when you don't need us and stuff because
when it's cool it's cool too you know it
used us to get big big up and then to
drop us that's what it feels like are
you trash man yeah it's just it's that
odd odd thing right cuz for me growing
up in that type of neighborhood and just
kind of grow brought black people my
whole life I also went to a black church
and everything out
wanted to be an R&B singer because of
like the black you know so it was like
my [ __ ] was funny but I just remember
just that identity crisis was such a
weird thing for me but I feel very
blessed that I did get to grow up in
such a culturally diverse area and I
think for me and like just a black
comedian age come here there's a lot of
[ __ ] similarities absolutely unreal
how similar we are absolutely you know
it's great like number one if you beat
your kids that's the similar it was
funny like I had a stand-up set one time
and I didn't so at the time we're
pulling up I just plugged the idea to
the GPS I don't know where I was going
they pull into this Korean church and I
was like yes I'd like I mean it was a
conference but I realized like is that a
Korean Church oh my god you know maybe
it's just at this church so I see a lot
of Honda Civics with spoilers and stuff
on my own that's an unusual amount of
like civics and stuff that's no big deal
and I go on it's like 600 Asian people
right high school college or my man I'm
finna bomb ya cuz at the time a lot of
my jokes were about my up group
upbringing being poor brought my first
about 15 20 minutes about how I grew up
poor family getting beat and stuff like
that bro the audience connected lazy you
would not believe
I'm like bro we literally have the exact
same experience yeah we got totally
different skin color everything else but
that experience with our parents was
verbatim they were rock and laughing
like black and also HB were like I was
like how they even gonna laugh cuz that
you keep our usual more reserved yeah
bro they had the time of their life and
I'm like bro we really grew up the same
way exactly because those jokes work
they don't work if you didn't grow up
like yeah you don't say so so yeah
there's definitely a lot of similarities
and we both be Fried Chicken oh for sure
dude laughs people love Asian people's
fried chicken so that's the [ __ ] I
didn't [ __ ] get right when I was a kid
so you know when you just grow up in a
black community a lot of these
stereotypes and a lot of these racial
words you don't hear until you're not
around black people I didn't know about
I didn't know the word spook was a was a
racial black term yeah yeah yeah we
heard about that [ __ ] when I went to
college yeah that's that yeah people
call into the spoon though
no there's some crazy-ass white people
start yeah there's some white people
[ __ ] out there like I remember just like
the fried chicken joke and the
watermelon joke did it make sense
because that's what Korean people love
love when you're when you're when you
have your it's called a peg it's like
you're a hundred day when you're a kid
mm-hmm you have fat [ __ ] watermelon
front of you yeah I got a picture with
me the kid with the [ __ ] if that
watermelon front of me and then the
Koreans number one drunk food is fried
chicken and beer no way yeah so Lucas
album so I was like right now that's our
[ __ ] but isn't but it's just something
that people use to make fun a black folk
but I'm like who doesn't like fried
chicken every bats why never understood
that everyone likes fried chicken yeah
like is that the were stereotyped like
who don't like Frankie just vegans but
people who like me
usually like fried chicken hey it's Anna
most people like if you don't like fried
chicken a walnut you're a rapist dude
how about that how about that you you
belong in jail you sick [ __ ] I'll put it
out there put that on a billboard right
now there's something wrong with you I
never understood those stereotypes it
was it was interesting though man like
especially well you did you said you
grew up all over the place because you
were in the military yeah my dad's in
military so I grew up well first my
first ten years were in El Paso and so I
grew up around 97% Hispanic people I
used to speak Spanish pretty well cuz
yeah and I fell out of it because I
moved around but when I was a kid you
were taught it in school and then
literally all my friends spoke Spanish
so I was always speaking Spanish and it
was great because he had to make you
know regular kids have burgers and
hotdogs at school lunch and El Paso it's
it's taquitos nachos quesadillas like
all Mexican food so that first ten years
was was bliss so I went from that to
like I remember when my dad we're moving
in North Carolina we lit went drove
through Atlanta and I had never seen
that many black people like outside of
my church like at a small church maybe
60 people and that was the most black
people I saw but in Atlanta was like the
pilots were black the flight attendants
were black everybody worked in
restaurants was black and I was like
yeah we really out
here like I did not know Blackie would
be out here like that so they move
around military bases it's obviously
like more diverse than most of America
but still like a lot of white people so
that military base growing up really
impacted who I was because you move
around so much that you really are
either extremely extrovert or extremely
introverted because you gotta you gotta
learn to make friends fast and your
friends like all my friends in a
three-year period
they all come there you have like maybe
18 months where you're all chillin and
then people start moving you don't I
mean so my kids like they've had the
same friends since like first grade
third grade because we moved here
finally and they've been one of the same
school like I even before my parents or
my dad was a military my parents got
Marilyn I was like 7 or 10 but you're
poor we moved around a lot you just like
rent gets high and all that type of
stuff so I always moved around a lot so
my kids be in the same school same
friends and like a little girl like my
son since he was like in 2nd grade and
now they're going into eighth grade and
I'm like man I don't even know I didn't
even well like yeah like each other
since you were in second grade or people
like remember in movies and they like
put a little like this is how tell timmy
was when he was 5 and 13 like bro we
first of all we couldn't write on the
walls
second of all we never stayed in no
place long enough to do that we weren't
like nobody owned homes like it's not a
lot of people own homes stuff like that
so all that stuff was really new to me
so I'm trying to like instill some of
that stuff in my kids and stuff but you
can seem really well-rounded they'll
mandate that is the greatest compliment
they seem very well-rounded not to mess
up a whole cuz we're a parent man you
really shaped somebody's worldview like
the way you see the world is more than
likely how they see they're gonna see
the exact way you do or turn a hundred
percent and do it the other way I'm
trying to make sure when I have kids
they don't ever hear me speak I don't
want them to be like me I got some harsh
as opinions about everything they're
gonna they're gonna be like you I hope
your mom your your wife a combination of
both is all you can hope for
because what your kids is gonna be all
David jr. dumbass Oh stupid I was so
dumb as a kid like oh god maybe they'll
take after you and later in life I hope
they don't know they don't know you they
only
you and your current forms I see some
other people and they're so kind and
they're very they know how to speak well
without speaking their mind too much
right yeah yeah man I wish I could just
take a little bit of that but the first
thing that comes on my mouth is like god
damn you know stupid [ __ ] dude I
just see I just want to say it so bad my
friends
just had a comment they go dude if we
said I just ate before I gave me a train
and he was telling me he goes you know
what last week he goes I know there's
something very interesting about you he
goes I could tell when you like somebody
you like them and when you hate them
it's apparent I'm the same way because
he goes you this dude was talking to you
and you just went and I tell him I do
that because if I say something I'm
gonna say something rude to him right so
I'd rather just be quiet and just let
him speak
you know just say he said he's talking
melting like like a [ __ ] ice cream
cone in mid-summer just starting to shut
the [ __ ] up and your kids will notice
that about you like my kids know when
I'm sitting like a fan meets me and
stuff they'll notice when I fake laugh
fake smile they're like yeah I really
want to take that picture we've been
around you bro we can tell when you like
when you take a picture with your friend
you take me to have a fan in ain't the
same yeah you be fake laughing man you
my orders to be like he be on me like
your fans deserve better
they're better so yo you know who's
really good at that [ __ ] tim is the best
at interacting with fans oh yes
Tim will go out of his way yes I contact
with somebody to make sure that they
know who he is
really I feel weird about that you know
why I feel worried about that because I
feel like I don't deserve that type of
praise me too I feel I do not deserve
you coming up to me and saying that I'm
a good person because I feel so
undeserving right you know so it's not
anything to do with you it's not that
I'm not appreciative it makes me feel
like would I can't I'm feel like I'm
sucking my own dick you you can tell
somebody recognizes you yeah but I never
want to be like ah you know me don't you
always have this further be like no no I
wasn't even looking at you know like Oh
like I don't know every what I feel like
that guy who like I you know me so yeah
I'd rather you come up and say hey cab
love you want to take a picture then to
me to be the one to do that cuz it feels
very like self-serving to me I learned a
big lesson to where mmm I used to hate
this thing where there's like 99% of the
time when somebody comes up to me you
get a picture and everything but there's
like a 1% where I don't want it cuz
maybe I'm not having a good day I'm
having time with my lady it's possible
which is possible but people don't like
that problem I think oh you think you're
better just happened to mean that 1%
where I just didn't feel it today yeah
human being yeah but check this [ __ ] out
I heard the story about Will Smith a
buddy of mine used to work in Interscope
and when he was working at Interscope
Will Smith got off his phone a business
call to come up to him and say hi to him
and take a picture with him have like a
five-minute conversation got back on his
phone and I was like wow if Will Smith
is doing that who the [ __ ] do I think I
am I'm a piece of [ __ ] I got a really
really valuable eat it [ __ ] Will
Smith catch you like like the worst time
for me is if I'm like just taking a
red-eye and you catch me in the airport
and I'm not even like you fly from your
Elliot Atlanta and you're walking around
at six-thirty it's like 3 o'clock in the
morning to your body yep and people
catch you like oh you don't seem to be
in a good mood like I'm not yeah I
haven't even slept on a plane which is
already trashed it feels like 3 o'clock
in the morning but the sun is shining
you are happy and cheery like that is a
tough spot and that's what people catch
me and I'm the worst stop but most of
the time I want to have a good
interaction because I don't want P to be
on Twitter like now I don't want follow
me for 10 years you were a jerk to me me
be tired yeah it's the same thing like
one time it was weird we flew to
Cleveland and a fan was like had come
there and like looked at the flights and
was like they're probably gonna be on
this 8:30 flight and from LA and she got
dressed she had makeup on and she waited
for the like when you come out of
security before you go to baggage claim
and she was like I knew you guys are on
that flight can I take a picture I've
been here for two hours hoping you guys
were on that flight and I studied the
airline stuff to make sure that you guys
are probably gonna be here because they
died that day she was going to kill you
she won't chop off your ear like mango
and put that in a box and that [ __ ]
would be game over
no one on earth I would ever spend that
much time researching a hundred percent
I love Will Smith Denzel would never in
a million years ever do even if I knew
they were coming like not crazy how much
you affect somebody's life though yes
like you were probably there for her at
a time where [ __ ] was going dark and
yeah laughs and that's what I think
that's different about us versus like
the wheel before he got on Instagram or
Denzel like if you're like a yourself a
fan like he's your favorite you watch
everything he does it's a movie maybe
two a year and then like a six-week
promo period that's all you can see if
you're a fan of mine or yours you can
watch a video every day your Instagram
your Twitter your stories like that's a
lot more of you to consume so when they
see you they feel like I know you
because I watched all your videos and
that's if you think about it we put out
much more content and a hundred percent
hours and hours and hours for years like
will they make a movie for like two or
three years yeah we give you you take
one year off you still have two more
years on Will Smith you know I mean when
you come back it's you know the engines
back on so people have consumed a lot
more content yeah so they're there like
when they see you that's that's it this
is my only chance like people don't
realize how rude they come off sometimes
I was in up New Orleans talking to my
sister we were at a club and she had a
drink in her hand I was like what's in
your drink and a girl came up and pushed
her was like actually keV I'm a bit like
literally with her elbow like push my
sister my sister is the youngest one she
was like super black she had brace she
like where they snatched the attitude in
the scenario bra she was livid and I'm
like this person does not understand how
rude yeah that was so I try to defuse
the situation because I know my sister
was about to go off something like then
that's the sister I don't care about
anyway and then yeah
apologize to her but people don't know
or they don't care they just they got to
take advantage of it that moment yeah
and I get that but something was righted
and yeah acted really weird I I've
definitely had situations where this is
the worst thing that has ever happened I
was talking on the phone with either was
of my mama was it Mary I either way I
can't remember but it was a serious
conversation with my mom very serious
conversation yeah and somebody rolled up
in a car
and number one is a dude who knows who I
am but he's acting like he doesn't know
who I am which is which is the most
irritating right so it's like I'm on the
phone and I'm sitting on a very serious
conversation the guy rolls up in his car
he goes hey I know you from somewhere
and I go hey what's up man how you doing
hey I'm on I'm on a serious phone call
with cookie just give me a second right
mm-hmm and I was talking about the phone
he goes hey real quick and I say
something funny and mind you I'm already
having a very irritating conversation I
was like well I'm on the phone can you
give me a second right he goes are you
too good for me and she literally went
down and I walked up to his floor I was
like I will [ __ ] you up dude I was like
the [ __ ] is wrong with you and I just
started going off right oh you'll get
the [ __ ] out the car [ __ ] you up that's
not [ __ ] man he goes oh I'm so sorry
man I was like then what the [ __ ] are
you gonna do man I'm like cuz you're
knocking me like you wanted to scratch
right okay I guess we're gonna have to
[ __ ] scrap now yeah I'll be on
YouTube as the guy would I beat up beat
up a fan that's what a TD fans are like
oh my god that's so popular
yeah they don't know you but they feel
like they do so they walk up and insult
you like that used to happen to us all
the time what up you milk dud head Boyle
ball headed like bride don't know you
like that brah I'll fight you yeah I
don't you don't mean like you imagine
doing that to somebody you don't know
like you're not gonna expect them to be
all without my boy bro who you think
you're talking to
yeah like and when I'm roasting I'm
roasting my boys exactly you are a
stranger like we laughing off camera
like I don't know you
yeah but they feel like because they
watch hours and hours of that content
that I dunno you know in some ways they
do if you're really who you are on
social media but that doesn't mean I
know you like personally you know I'm
saying you're a stranger to me so people
don't understand yeah and it's funny
because that dude wrote something on
Twitter oh yeah about it and then I
responded back to him and I remember cuz
he respond respond back to him miles I
know I'll tell you what the real story
is and I started getting on him aside
now you were disrespected deleted his
tweet they want a page that's what I'm
talking about that interaction where he
was clearly the rude one of this
interaction yeah he gonna go online and
try to make you the bad guy a hundred
there was another person to who was
talking all big saying that they said
some [ __ ] to me me of all people so she
was saying that well he he was saying
that he was talking some [ __ ] to me and
I didn't say anything at all yeah right
and this is somebody that I know oh
right and he went back home and he was
telling people that oh that I'm mr.
Hollywood and I was a saint [ __ ] too
when he was talking [ __ ] about a second
me not talk back right that's a part of
my brandy what do you mean don't sound
like you at all so I assumed that he
said this in like a drunken stupor with
like a group of our you know friends or
associates or what Yeah right but no he
was telling that story to individual
people and it came back to me and they
were saying like yo did he say this this
and that he's been saying this and that
about you he goes is this true cuz it
sound like you right I was like when you
guys are smart
cuz I'm no no way I'm a little [ __ ]
dweeb out Ward Smith me you know what
I'm saying
you have [ __ ] gut you are out of your
[ __ ] mind went back recently and I
was like yo let's meet up and talk about
this not in the fight type of way but it
was aight let's what's your problem with
me
right that's not like that laughing they
got the story twisted out that's funny
because then four or five people that
the story twisted then twist it exactly
right exactly like they all got to twist
it in this exact way that means you
probably was telling that story like
yeah it's like what does that do for you
it I thought we were friends [ __ ] you
know I mean like what the [ __ ] but then
you know one of my friends put it to me
like this he goes you know it's it's
it's a situation where somebody doesn't
feel good about their life so whenever
you're doing well and you know for a
majority of my friends were really proud
of you right but there are a few select
people that will say bad things about
you because things aren't going well in
their life people project on you
positively or negatively yeah they
didn't join you and your trips and all
that stuff or that I wholly think he is
he ain't better than me like either way
they're projecting yeah yes this yeah oh
[ __ ] man we got through this podcast
like nothing usually is podcast about 30
minutes or 30 minutes I feel like I keep
going but Wow you know we back on again
man let's get it man so yeah this was
fun
hey but what can they find you kid keV
on stage on everything Twitter Instagram
YouTube Facebook that's a smart move I
should have kept this as the Davis o
comedy podcast I switch is that the
genius brain so you were just like I'm
genius right all the way I'm not going
back exactly and I [ __ ] up
I was like I'm about this [ __ ] and then
I looked back I was like I need to
change this [ __ ] back I [ __ ] it all up
nobody gives a [ __ ] about their like
whose genius brain I forgot to tell
people that's the thing I [ __ ] up I
forgot to tell people like who the [ __ ]
is this and I lost like ten thousand
subscribers of that hold on a second
tell people I was doing this did I but
came on stage on everything you can
listen to this podcast on Spotify any
type of audio platform iTunes podcast
leave in the comments below what you
think about keV and everything that he's
saying you know I'm the biggest fan of
this guy ever you guys the funniest
[ __ ] on earth okay next year
when you do a stand-up special i'ma have
you pull up I'm but I'm about this I'm
about to throw my underwear at you and
I'm a big boy - that shit's about to
come down like a parachute
[Music]
[Laughter]